oh this was painful to watch hey
everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
video is sponsored by ritual and today
we'll be talking about everything wrong
with the new hit lifestyle series 1000
pound sisters but first let me tell you
about my sponsor ritual now i know a lot
of you are actively trying to conceive
are already pregnant or are recently
postpartum and looking to maintain your
health during this new phase of life i
know this supplement world is super
overwhelming but i like rituals prenatal
because it's third party tested anna has
12 high quality nutrients like
methylated fourth generation folate b12
d3 and omega-3 ritual is all about
focusing their multivitamins on the
nutrients that you actually need and
they're really transparent about where
they source their nutrients and why as
well as their environmental impact so
for example they use 100 recycled
materials in their packaging and their
mailers are made from recycled newsprint
and plant fibers their malty is also
vegan gluten-free allergen-free with no
colorants added sugars additives or
enlisted ingredients they also have a
regular multivitamin for men and women a
50-plus option a post-needle option and
one specifically for teens but it's
super convenient because they just
deliver right to your door as part of a
subscription so even if you're having
super mom brain you won't run out so if
you're looking to conceive or you just
want to fill in some of those potential
nutritional gaps with a multi you can
use my promo code and check out the link
in the description to get 10 off of your
first three months of ritual and you can
pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating i'm going to be
showing some potentially very triggering
video clips and discussing disordered
eating so as always please feel free to
skip this video if it's not supportive
to your journey and if you're not
already subscribed hit that sub button
and follow me over on tick tock and
instagram abby's kitchen alrighty so as
a brief backgrounder on tlc's one
thousand pound sisters the show follows
sisters amy and tammy who based on the
series title have a combined weight of
over one thousand pounds much like tlc's
my 600 pound life which i reviewed right
here the show documents how amy and
tammy navigate life in larger bodies
while trying to qualify for bariatric
surgery and while this show joins
countless others that position
themselves as inspirational
entertainment
that sounds fake but
okay
you and i both know the damage it can do
so
we're gonna talk about it no holds
barred so let's get into everything
wrong with one thousand pound sisters
starting with problem number one it
fuels fat phobia and hate watching this
is not the first show to riff on this
theme like a thousand pound best friends
too large my 600 pound life on heavy
family by the time etc etc etc it's
clearly evident that fat phobic
curiosity continues to be a common
entertainment chip that is used to drive
tv ratings and fuel voyeuristic hate
watching haters cause they anus they
hate us because we anus whether it's one
thousand pound sisters or any other
similarly sensationalized series human
beings living in a body that is
different or shocking to others is
generally the focal point of the show as
a result amy and tammy are strongly
defined by their weight how it impacts
their lives and whether or not they're
able to meet their weight loss goals and
while i'm sure that many viewers tune
into the show for their sisterly banter
and heartwarming life successes like
amy's pregnancy we also see a very dire
and intimate portrayal of their lives
tammy in particular has struggled
significantly with a slew of medical
issues and mental health struggles so
she was admitted to rehab for food
addiction was on life support and
suffered from severe depression and
suicidal thoughts but rather than giving
tammy the space and support that she
needs during this difficult time her
struggle is instead used as a plotline
to showcase her descent towards rock
bottom so we see her living in isolation
gaining more weight struggling to walk
binge drinking and even requiring the
assistance of a house nurse this is all
intentionally juxtaposed against amy who
has successfully lost weight had the
surgery and is now living her dream of
starting a family so this carefully
crafted storyline positions weight loss
as the happily ever after solution to a
life of eternal misery and solitude and
while i am certainly not denying that
weight loss or even bariatric surgery in
these extreme cases can significantly
improve health outcomes and quality of
life it is also not a quick fix solution
and i'm going to discuss the
implications of weight loss surgery as a
quick fix later on in the video but my
point here is that shows like this shed
a very undignified light on their
subjects for entertainment purposes
rather than approaching these very real
people with very real struggles with
empathy compassion and dignity they're
portrayed as societal outcasts
undeserving of respect shows like this
do not breed compassion they breed fear
disgust
and prejudice perpetuating the narrative
that obesity is a choice and that brings
me to my next point there eat less move
more recommendations rbs so research has
shown that negative attitudes towards
obese folks continues to be on the rise
and content like this just reinforces
the stereotype that larger body folks
are lazy and unmotivated generally
speaking morbid obesity has little to do
with just lack of motivation or lack of
knowledge in amy and tammy's case both
sisters understand that caloric density
and food quantity contributes to their
weight they also both have their own
motivations for losing weight which is
required to qualify for surgery to
improve their lives so amy also has the
additional motivation to conceive while
tammy is desperate to improve her
mobility so why is weight loss in these
situations so difficult well a lot of
what we don't see on shows like this is
the important connection between obesity
and mental health we didn't really get
much love
and affection growing up we got told we
were stupid we were lazy
ugly fat
it's
comforting to
eat
because i know food is not
going
to i was gonna say harm me but it is
okay just as we have seen in my 600
pound life a common thread among morbid
obese folks is childhood trauma so in
amy and tammy's case not only does this
include the loss of their beloved
grandmother whom they consider to be a
mother figure but also the cruel
bullying and isolation they experienced
as kids not only can weight stigma cause
psychological damage but it also
actually perpetuates weight gain so one
study on more than 2 400 overweight and
obese women reported that 79 of
participants coped with the weight
stigma by eating more food and 75 of
participants coped by refusing to diet
experiencing weight stigma early on in
childhood paired with the grief and
isolation of said stigma can actually
cause deep-rooted long-term effects on
the brain so much so that it can even
inhibit an individual's ability to
experience positive emotions this is why
folks with significant childhood trauma
are more likely to experience depression
as adults and rely on unhealthy coping
mechanisms like food to self-soothe
but trying to make changes in my life is
very difficult i was deeply depressed
growing up and i was literally like the
only thing that made me feel better was
to eat food is a comfort it's like your
friend so when you're on a diet it's
like losing your best friend so
expecting that people in larger bodies
just need to pull up their bootstraps to
eat less and exercise more without
addressing the underlying trauma is not
only clinically unhelpful but it
actively can do more harm and this is
why the obesity guidelines now suggest
that it's more important to focus on the
root cause of weight gain and
sustainable behaviors rather than
suggesting that individuals just eat
less to weigh less it doesn't really
work like that now in addition to mental
and emotional challenges to weight loss
we also need to consider the systemic
barriers at play which brings me to my
next point shows like this dismiss the
societal factors that contribute to
obesity the common narrative around
obesity is that it's a consequence of
someone's choices and is therefore an
individual's responsibility to fix by
making better choices however this
assumption about the cause of obesity
dismisses all of the systemic factors
that are much stronger predictors of
obesity than any single meal in other
words someone's external environment and
socioeconomic status can play a far more
significant role in their health
outcomes than simply their lifestyle we
grew up very poor we grew up with fast
food mostly but there was five kids so
our mom worked three jobs i got to be
honest i never bought really healthy
food in the past but this time i'm gonna
buy some tomato onion avocados
cucumbers lettuces this experience is
not uncommon among folks from low-income
households who have limited access to
nutrient-dense foods in fact research
has shown that fast food outlets are
more accessible in low-income
communities whereas access to
supermarkets and grocery stores with a
variety of fresh foods are more limited
it's therefore no surprise that living
in a low-income community with greater
access to convenience foods is a strong
predictor of obesity amy herself has
even acknowledged that one of the
challenges she's experienced in trying
to eat healthier comes down to
differences in affordability and
accessibility where purchasing a burger
for a buck is much easier than buying a
salad for five dollars now many have
been quick to criticize her remark as an
excuse to continue eating calorie dense
foods but given the statistics and her
family's economic history i think it's a
very real valid barrier to behavioral
change moreover we also know that
poverty induces scarcity mentality
especially when the experience of
poverty is deep seeded from childhood
which can then perpetuate binge eating
behaviors in other words coming from a
place of caloric or food insecurity
causes you to overcompensate later on in
life i mean a lot of us who had
grandparents in the war can attest to
their butter hoarding tendencies it's a
similar phenomenon memories of
insecurity imprint very very hard so now
we've got childhood weight stigma
childhood trauma poverty induced
scarcity mentality and mobility
challenges all making it very difficult
to break the cycle and this speaks to
just how complex obesity is and why
punitive advice like this if you care
about something bad enough it'll be a
priority and if you don't it won't be a
priority it's really that simple it's
actually not that simple when you
consider the bigger picture and it also
completely ignores the very real and
valid reasons why following any type of
diet protocol can be extremely
challenging which brings me to my next
point restrictive diets like those shown
on the show come with significant risk
now in order for amy and tammy to
qualify for bariatric surgery they have
to get their weight down to
550 pounds now this is a common
recommendation that's necessary to
qualify for surgery as excess fat around
the abdomen and liver can increase the
risk of complications so to help
facilitate their preliminary weight loss
they enlist the support of a dietitian
the dietitian wants us to throw out all
the junk food and all the stuff we can
eat
but drinking saudis eating cookies on
this diet you're supposed to drink
protein shakes twice a day
the doctor said this is a good way to
lose weight a lot of protein a lot of
protein less carbs first up is peaches
and cream
it was a rotten peach now while there's
no consensus on a standard pre-op diet
for bariatric patients when i consulted
with my dietitian colleagues they
suggested that the general
recommendation is a high protein low
carb and low to moderate fat diet and by
the sounds of it this is what has been
recommended to tammy and amy the reason
for this is because a high protein diet
will help to preserve lean muscle mass
and support post-surgery recovery while
a low-carb diet can help to facilitate
weight loss faster
however a common challenge here is that
pre-op patients are often told what to
eat but not how to eat and for folks who
lack cooking skills a lot of food
knowledge have limited access to grocery
stores with affordable fresh food or who
have strong emotional ties to food this
advice just isn't going far enough
another challenge here is that the
recommended pre-op diet is very low in
calories usually around a thousand to
1200 calories sometimes as low as 450 to
800 calories according to my dietitian
colleagues this is to force the body to
use up glycogen stores for fuel which
helps to essentially shrink the liver to
provide more visibility during the
procedure resulting in a safer surgical
outcome now as we discussed a bunch of
times here there are absolutely
metabolic risks to following a very low
calorie diet but in clinical cases like
this medical professionals have to weigh
out the benefits and risks regardless
slashing your calories in like a quarter
or so is no easy feat for anyone never
mind someone who has historically used
food to cope and i really do worry about
the risk of viewers attempting kind of
copycat diets at home to lose weight
fast that sounds dangerous and that
brings me to my last point weight loss
surgery is not a quick
fix there is no question that weight
loss surgery can be a viable and
life-changing solution for some folks in
fact research has consistently shown
that weight loss surgery can help
patients lose up to 70 of excess weight
not only can weight loss surgery improve
the physical and metabolic outcomes of
obesity but it can also improve overall
quality of life and we've seen a
beautiful success story in amy who is
able to conceive and carry a successful
pregnancy to term thanks to her surgery
and weight loss however despite its
possible benefits we also know that
weight loss surgery is no quick fix and
comes with its own risks surges no
guarantee that somebody's going to not
only lose the weight but keep the weight
off
and we've seen that from what i'm seeing
she hasn't put any more effort back into
her health we've pretty much stalled out
at this point so amy's stalled weight
loss is not uncommon as research
suggests that weight loss starts to
decline about a year or so post-op
weight regain is also not uncommon with
one long-term studies showing that 93 of
patients maintained only 10
of their weight loss 12 years post-op
it's also important to note that the
incidence of binge eating disorder is
estimated to be as high as 69
among bariatric patients while increased
rates of depression are around 13
it's also worth flagging that suicide
rates for bariatric patients can be
three to four times greater compared to
the general population often as a result
of depression persistent weight
struggles binge eating symptoms and
other unexpected outcomes like excess
skin the bottom line here is that weight
loss surgery is not brain surgery and
unless the underlying relationship with
food and all of the other challenges
that we just discussed are addressed the
risks may outweigh the benefits
glamorizing weight loss surgery on shows
like this does nothing to illustrate the
uphill battle that people living with
obesity face since most tv shows portray
surgery as like a quick fix that just
requires a little bit of money and a
little bit of motivation and i hope this
video helps to illustrate why i hate
watching people's struggles is grossly
problematic let's take a look
gross more empathy less hate and on that
note that is all that i have for you
guys today thank you again to ritual for
sponsoring if you like this video please
be sure to give it the thumbs up leave
me a comment below with any other shows
you guys want to see me review subscribe
to the channel and i'll see you next
time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]